the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
basically you're not gonna be able to
use this Beatles clip unfortunately but
can I hear what it what the song is yes
so the reason why this is under Creative
Commons which it's a little sketchy i'm
not sure if it would intimately could
have done that but it's because they've
transformed it so much to the extent
that it's like no longer the original
work right so if it revert it to the
original work then you're also reverting
you're like taking away the Creative
Commons work basically
me
and you like this instrumental you could
find something like this on ccmixter
avenue zip archive it'll take a while
and unfortunately i don't have a
shortcut that's the problem with music
is that it's not catalog very well so
it's time consuming because you just
have to listen to everything well what
would be like a good like a good mood to
search for that all right I wouldn't
necessarily search by mood I would
search by instrumentation okay so have
you looked at any of those links that
were up on the syllabus and I mean this
is sort of like chill Rock basically
okay and that may not actually narrow it
down and go ahead and try to explore
other genres too I unfortunately there's
no like quick algorithm for finding good
music that's why it's so time consuming
but let me see what you've got cut so
far okay the video mm-hmm all right do
you mind if I bump up your brightness a
little bit oh yeah better and i'll
delete this song
first I draw an equilateral triangle
divide each side into three parts and
draw another equilateral triangle on top
of each one then take out the middle and
repeat the process this time with 1 2 3
4 times 3 which is 12 sides eventually
the shape will start looking something
like this in mathematics this is called
a cop snowflake if I repeated my process
again and again I would see this same
pattern anywhere I looked this is a cop
smells like this time this won't be an
animation and just such note and
insurance that on any scale on any level
of zoom look roughly the same are called
fractals computer scientists can program
these infinite patterns by repeating
often simple mathematical process over
and over in the 1990s a radio astronomer
named Nathan Cohen used fractals to
revolutionize telecommunications at the
time Cohen was having troubles with his
Lantern the man wouldn't let him put an
antenna on Israel so go and design a
more compact fractal radio antenna
instead the landlord inverted and it
worked better than the ones before
working further Cohen design
we met response from and response is not
really this but you'd be scrubbing in
backward but you can still think the
package imagine with water and soap
anything responses holds except the
water is life line and the soap is say
good holiday the fractals infinite
spunkiness allows it to receive many
different frequencies simultaneously
before apparent intention and Tenace had
to be cut for one frequency and it was
the only frequency they could operate
that so with outcomes sponge your cell
phone would have to look something like
a hedgehog to receive multiple signals
including the one your friends use will
be called go in later proved but all the
fractal shapes could work with such a
wide range of frequencies today millions
of wireless communication devices Rob
Dodson Barker oh those are the me those
I was testing something okay I was like
what was happier recording yeah I'm
gonna do it then vices you
let's go
I was like earlier somewhere up there
this come on genius invention however
was not the first application of frat
doesn't level oh I should do it yet
let's do this and it's there are empty
yes it's
including laptops and barcode scanners
use Cohen's fractal antenna colors
genius invention however was not the
first application of fractals in the
world her hands are Alicia husband doing
it the whole time and not just with
snowflakes natural selection favors the
most efficient systems and organisms
often a fractal shake for example the
spiral fractal is present in broccoli
seashells and hurricanes the fractal
tree is relatively easy to program and
can be used to study river systems blood
vessels and lightning bolts so many
natural systems previously thought
off-limits to mathematicians can now be
explained in terms of fractals
alright that's a good start good start
um so I think in general the transitions
could be a little bit tighter so like
right here when you walk off well this
hiccup is like really noticeable mm-hmm
so either hide it by having an extreme
close up before you leave or just get
rid of this entirely although I know
that you did that to show the walk off
so that you could show walking in and I
can connect these were this is actually
one video I separated so I could speed
this up oh and I guess I was hanging
around with that I almost think this
happens to quickly though yeah it's a
140 right now yeah I was until I fell
back down yeah um so let's go scene by
scene
is this track Creative Commons no it's
Aerosmith I would okay that is a simply
good term there's probably an eye movie
sound effect actually that you can use
okay um for this part where you're just
like walking on I would digitally zoom
and close up because otherwise you jump
to talking all of a sudden but um your
movement wasn't exaggerated enough to
where you like get the joke that you're
talking so you can exaggerate it by
changing the actual framing of the scene
so would i zoom in when I started
talking I I would stay zoomed in when
you're talking and then clean cut to a
wider shot of you afterwards so
basically I would cut
like right there okay and I don't
remember had my versions a little bit
different dollars um but I would cut
right there and for the preceding clip i
would do you know how to crop and zoom
on um yeah i can you just go like that
basically yeah for that now for this i
would also work this is basically one
really long shot that is framed the
exact same way and it's very luxury
because you're literally out of
blackboard although I I think that that
was a good setup for you guys given the
complexity of explaining this but I
think you can avoid making it sound too
chalkboard luxury by cutting in and out
of your frame okay of your framing so
this is fine first I draw an equilateral
like right there I would save your audio
but just cut to a close up of your hand
drawing it the next time you had any
sense triangle so kind of like with the
phone when I'm showing yeah yeah okay I
would do more of that I think in general
you have very static shots that last for
a long time so you can break that up by
keeping the same track from your one
long take mm-hmm but mixing up the
extent to which you zoomed in okay yeah
that's what sort of the phone so it can
definitely yeah I wait on that I think
that would help because this section is
pretty long like if you just even look
at your project this file is this is 32
seconds which it's the video is about
three minutes and 40 seconds right now
okay then like this part is because I
inserted the song oh okay okay great he
did my process again and again
I would see this see so I guess you
could zoom in yes sir [ __ ] I actually I
wouldn't um I feel like you're revealing
this image too soon in your sentence if
I repeated this process over and over
again I would see this image and I
wouldn't I almost don't want to see that
image until you say this image okay
right so maybe if you can zoom in and
frame and crop out the fractal zoom in
until you say this and then at this you
can either pan to the drawing or you can
cut to a wide shot okay if I repeated my
process again and again I would see this
same pattern anywhere I looked and um
anywhere you looked I mean it is there a
way to like shoot footage of just close
ups of the snowflake of you like going
around the edge of the foot of the
periphery of the snowflake so that would
be this now be that part okay yeah this
is a cocktail which this is a software a
fractal drawing software I'm allowed to
like film the zoom in on that and then
used it depends on if the what license
the software is released under and who
created that image okay so I mean I
didn't have to pay for it or anything oh
you created the image no well so kind of
it's just a software and then you can do
let's say you draw a [ __ ] snowflake and
then you can just zoom in on it and then
I just another three open source
software um yeah I was free
you know what you should do is you
should just take a quick time recording
of your screen like what yeah that's
what I just like do a quick time
recording of you zooming in and that's
okay to use yeah all right oh this is so
trippy ah why make it stop I don't
actually know like I work too much
there's a video of somebody doing that
which is well done so i may use part of
that um you I ideally you would make
your own video yeah I'll work on the
maybe I'll just like track their
movements at least yeah because I don't
know what the details of that would be
if you're actually allowed to use that
video unless they've specifically
released it under creative commons um
all right here this is a cop snowflake
this time draw it on a computer such
never-ending patterns so should be a
local zoo look roughly the same are
called fractals hmm
okay this is where you change your
wardrobe all of a sudden ideally that
wouldn't happen wardrobe changes are
okay if it makes sense but here it seems
like a little arbitrary but it's not the
end of the world
does that make sense why that seems a
little bit weird though because it's
like in your script there's nothing that
sort of signifies or identifies that
you've shot like at a different day or
that you're in a location that requires
a different wardrobe you know is a cop
snowflake this time draw it on a
computer such never-ending patterns that
on any scale on any level of zoom look
roughly the same are called fractals
okay I'm just going to say it how do you
pronounce koch snowflake i'm pretty sure
it's see k OCH right just because i
would imagine that it's educators
watching this video but if there are
little children watching this one
they're gonna be Sam her he said [ __ ]
snowflake again I was actually thinking
of doing because the sound changes so
much I was actually thinking of doing a
voiceover this because when i found i
recorded this part indoors and outdoors
and i could match up the sound perfectly
okay for what I was moving so if I'd
like to do the same thing but yeah where
else i can probably match up the sound
and change the snowflake pride Helga
bond coke
yeah I would just look out the
pronunciation of that just say all right
just to be careful um yeah and
especially like this is just vo stuff
anyway so you can easily rerecord that
so wait wait for the reveal here
basically do a little more with cutting
in and out of close-ups and wide shots
um okay right here on how practice so
this reveal is a little awkward because
you're not looking at the audience when
you're saying the big reveal and then
you have this sort of unnatural pause
before you start the next I was actually
originally intending to stay fractals
here but I cut it over and I see thought
oh well just say that but originally it
was going to be I finished saying friday
and then i type on the computer and say
okay that'll work a lot better so I'll i
can just reduce okay cool i mean i think
it's also if you I think ideally you
would say fractals and then you'd look
down at your computer but what you're
saying now that'll work yeah and that's
how we filmed it so yeah because this
like gap and where you take your breath
it sounds fine but it looks a little
awkward computer scientists can program
these infinite patterns but um so this
is super overexposed in the background
so I'm going to try to see if you can
bring the exposure down just a little
bit okay I don't remember how to do that
maybe it's on this actually increase the
exposure cuz I'm challenge but I can
peer in yeah I mean the main thing is
the whites right like you're super blown
out in the back in the window patterns
by repeating album no it was different
in the original her and I don't know if
you can if there's a history on iMovie
but if you can somehow just like
increase the blacks but don't blow out
the whites that might help if you have
weird shadows going on
I think so it looked like this
originally I think oh yeah that's better
yeah I don't know i was playing around
with that but that's not the final
version okay cool but that was the
original god I'd like oh yeah I remember
this one also feels pretty long to me
computer scientists can program these
infinite patterns by repeating and also
simple mathematical process over and
over so for that line do you have
footage of you on matlab graphing a
fractal I can do that because I'd
probably be on the fractal software yeah
yeah even that like just to break it up
a little bit and give them like a visual
Association because this is one of those
times where if you were like again in a
static placing the st. like a big chunk
of words to them it's sort of easier to
tune it up a little bit fractals
computer scientists can program these
infinite patterns by repeating also
simple mathematical process over and
over in the 1990s yeah and then cut back
out to you when you set them because
that's like a very separate fart a radio
astronomer named Nathan coat is there a
picture Nathan Cohen that could like pop
up on the side I can probably find that
yeah yeah there is one actually telstra
revolutionize telecommunications oh okay
so halfway through the video you switch
to these like you turn transitions mhm
um I mean this is this personal
preference i don't know how you feel
about transition um but I feel like
either keep it all the same or use like
the little quirkier transitions for you
know very pointed reason that I'm for
this one because it was such different
locations I use these to tell the story
so this is me introducing a story and
telling the story so just for that store
i'm using those transitions yeah i think
if you're going to do that I much prefer
a push rather
and a cube turn and because we've we've
done that once before and again personal
preference George had to really sell me
on the idea cuz I was very opposed to it
but instead of doing a rotation you just
it's a wipe basically one frame pushes
off and reveals the next one I think
that looks a little bit better basically
I prefer a subtle Tran transition as
possible and the animations are cool but
they remind people of like really flashy
homemade videos as opposed like this is
a very iMovie transition yeah at the
time Cohen was having troubles with his
landlord the man wouldn't let him put an
antenna on this so there's some wait let
me listen to this again done Cohen was
having troubles with his landlord the
man would let him put an antenna on his
room so go and design a more compact
flat there I would zoom in mm-hmm cut to
a closer framing of that so ready that's
like just the wire yo antenna instead
the landlord didn't notice it and it
worked better than the ones day for
working further and then come back and
one designed a new antenna this time
using the Fraxel called the vengers
sponge and again I don't think it's
necessary to do that a rotation I was
thinking here while the maybe have the
meander sponge increase in size and then
have curtain as a background so would
that be another transition rights to
kind of have the mentor sponge expand
and then have me wipe it off are you
going to have a model of it hopefully
response
so you're going to sorry are you going
to refill the part with with like a
model or like just like a image okay
okay so would pop up in your hand right
there so this the way this is framed I
mean the subject is really here is going
to be here and it's so but you're so
biased I mean this is beautifully framed
in terms of like rule of thirds and
everything but because you held your
hand out this way yeah it's going to
look really fun like the visual balance
of that frame is going to look really
funny when you're like mend your sponge
and then all of a sudden it's like huge
thing gets cut off on the side mm-hmm so
either zoom in a little bit I mean
ideally you would have held out this
hand so that it would have been in the
middle although the background is really
distracting so I don't know if your
sponge and are you going to hold oh so
I'm assuming the mend your sponge
picture will be floating somewhere um it
would be here yeah but then I would get
rid of it when I'm talking about the
regular sponge well here you're here it
would still be floating because I think
when you're saying the meander sponge
isn't exactly like a real sponge right
but i think the mend your sponge needs
to be shown okay if you're going to show
something show it long enough to where
the viewer can process it a little bit
otherwise it's like this blip that might
distract this okay
your sponge hold did you cut right here
or do is there a little bit more I think
there's a little bit more okay yeah
leave hold it just a little bit and
maybe cut two again cut to a close up
shot that can be sort of a workaround to
the weird framing issue otherwise it's
like it's really nicely done you can say
the meander sponge in the pop-up right
there imagine with water and soap and
it's your sponges holes except the water
is life I episode is sick yeah so here
the timing of you turning on the water
is a little bit weird because you turn
it on like way after you save water and
so um and I wonder if were you planning
on doing an animation for this section
because I feel like this is a spot where
it actually would be beneficial to not
even have an overlay but a completely
separate animation of like a sponge with
holes and like h2o and soap with arrows
pointing like going into the Sun tools
what do you think sorry yeah are just to
like demonstrate that concept because it
you it's easier to understand when you
read it and when you hear it in a couple
of seconds yeah and I think like the
this visuals of this again it's a pretty
long it's what it's 14 seconds it's
actually kind of long to have the same
sort of still framing um if you like how
its framed it's another you could also
just overlay yeah a little like a little
arrow pointing in because you hold it
pretty still
yeah like you could just have you know
h2o and soap with arrows pointing into
the sponge and then coming out of the
sponge episode is yeah but I I almost
would um you can leave it in for the
rough cut and we can see what other
people say but the sorry the movement of
that is is almost distracting because it
has nothing to do with what you're
saying when you're saying it right do
you have another take of this all of
them are kind of like this is a Zacks
event him the might be one when I finish
talking and then turn on the water so I
could use that yeah because if you cut
it right here and you didn't turn on the
water then that would have been that
wasn't better I think they're not like
that that I can use and again this one
like I wouldn't even I wouldn't do it a
push at all like i really i really think
sorry it looks a lot better when you do
as clean transitions as you can the
fractals is in its punchiness allows it
I would shave off maybe like a half
second because you like you take a
breath and then it takes like Justin
hair before you actually start talking
ok so just snip just like the tiniest
bit off the lobby annapolis and it's
pungent are you planning on doing any
animations to the side allows it to
receive i probably can put him in
response there and like signals come bad
yeah cuz otherwise again like nice rule
of thirds but you have a bath is that
like a bathroom stall yeah yeah so it's
like a really awkward Vishal yeah but
it's a good background it's a good
background if you wanted to put a
picture of ender sponge receiving like
different signals Collins invention
antennas had to be cut for one frequency
yeah so like show an old in Tennessee
and I was the only frequency they could
operate that so yeah and like right here
so without comes sponge your cell phone
would have to look something like a
hedgehog I would so you there's like a
bit of a hesitation before you say
without Cohen sponge and I don't even
think you need this so so I would just
cut out the pause and the so and cut
straight to without Cohen sponge and
then to hide that cut you can either
zoom in a little bit more so okay sponge
your cell phone would happen yeah and
like for that since you're not going to
have the animation i would i would frame
it and zoom in to where it's just you
and the resolution is going to look a
little funky but I think it's worth a
compromise to do that and it helps lead
into because like start leading the
viewer into seeing your phone because
it's like you're starting out with a
wide shot and then now you're on you and
then you'll eventually over your phone
and so like just a helps the narrative
along yeah and again I wouldn't rip
alive just go straight into that
signals including the one your friends
use when we call once i got that
transition yeah this one you could I
mean because it's such a different ways
at the end yeah on the end of the story
yeah maybe you could do a push common
later approved but only fractals but
it's still part of the same story so I I
I would say just do a clean cut there
too okay um but it is a little it's
still a little overexposed here yes I
was very much a title yeah yeah so clean
transition there I would cut out this
gap too it's just like the slightest
it's too long by just like this
slightest amount of time Cohen later
proved but only fractal shapes could
work and that's actually what makes it
read um sort of newscaster II you know
like have you ever seen the special
special segments you know and the
reporters like on their couch and it
like did that it under that and then
this person did this so it's just like
this tiny little gaps that make it read
that way but if you heard of it then
it'll be a lot more natural in such a
wide range of frequencies today millions
of wireless communication devices
including laptops and barcode scanners
use Cohen's fractal antenna come on
genius invention however was not the
first application of fractals in the
world so I'm gonna change that audio as
well because i think that was to grant
and I I have other versions that may
work better okay I like this a camera
slow pan off actually I yeah we did
another version which had also this
and it wasn't as good but I said the
next sentence after that so it sounds
more natural hmm so I'm going to see if
I can trade off the visual for do you
okay
so this is why this transition is a
little bit funny here the speed at which
you're moving the camera when you pan
off is way faster than when you pan down
on to you so what you could do is cut
this clip into two and speed up the
first part like you did earlier also is
this broccoli it is broccoli there's a
mural and instead I didn't know that was
broccoli it looked like bags of seeds or
something in maybe it looked like
broccoli enough so it looks like
cauliflower turns out nature um it
actually made me cauliflower I think
I've confused the words is filming so um
yeah I movie I hate you okay so if you
just press here I mean it's
indistinguishable and it looked like
bags the stuff of us um I can still like
to think like once or just an image of
broccoli so doing today millions of
wireless communication devices including
laptops and barcode scanners use Cohen's
fractal antenna colors genius invention
however was not the first application of
fractals in the world
yeah the pan just needs to happen sooner
okay if I would even like speed the pan
off mm-hmm and then speed up the pan
down right because it's like you're
waiting for the camera to get to move
off of you come on genius invention
however was not the first application of
fractals in the world are you planning
on reshooting any of this for sure turns
out nature husband do you the whole time
some seems like I can be she this one
and the one in the class selection
favors the most official once in each
campus I don't think that yeah I think
that's a tiny organisms often of a
fractal shake for example the spiral
fractal is present in broccoli seashells
and heart yeah because I think
especially with this one I mean oh I
know ok so the broccoli but i think the
brock of the spiral fractures are most
president it's like Romanesco broccoli
or something like that and so like it's
a specific it's a specific type and so
people might be confused with and like
look at their normal broccoli and like I
would show a picture of the Romanesco
broccoli especially because I don't
think this is called like I think this
is bags of barley or cotton nomas um
that would make more sense it's also
where the person is up there yeah and I
I think also it just like doesn't really
gosh it doesn't look like a fractal
whereas the broccoli actually their
visualizations of it where it actually
looks like oh I can identify this as a
fractal and so it'll just like it'll be
reassuring for your viewer when they can
see the picture the broccoli and be like
oh I can totally see how that's a
fractal rather than me like squinting at
your background I mean like is that like
did I learn anything from this video
yeah I think if you're going to reshoot
this part and like if you can't get it
this weekend that's okay remember you
still have wednesday to do it um I would
be careful about the way you're
emphasizing words its kind of falling a
little into the top of what George was
saying about
how news presenters and precise every
third word just to sound sort of in
there their emphasis e important
thoughts but they don't really make
sense where they're emphasizing the
words right so I would just try try a
few different types of deliveries one
where you're actually emphasizing every
other word on purpose and then you know
do something like completely exaggerated
and then try one where you're sort of
more natural tone talking well i think
that's how i use you to present like in
real life the whole time I'm not just
with smoke fractals in the world
remember that your remember that eighth
grade PhD thing you're talking for
eighth graders but you're not talking
necessarily to a ten-year-old right so
how would you say this line turns out
major husband doing you the whole time
how would you say that line to like your
professor I mean I wouldn't say this
lens in my professor how would you say
that line to to Jamie turns out feature
has been doing it the whole time yeah
that's a little bit different like turns
out nature's been doing it the whole
time um or I mean it's such a subtle
nuance but it's just something about
like tops and barcode scanners use
Cohen's fractal antenna colors genius
invention however was not the first
application of fractals in the world
turns out rachel has been doing you the
whole time I think it's the way you say
time Nature has been doing it the whole
time I mean it's okay to say it the
whole time but it reads like a little
reading rainbow and the intonation is
like that but again maybe that's just my
personal taste I in general I think your
enthusiasm is really really good like
you're taking a subject that's
inherently a little bit hard to
visualize it's a little bit tedious and
because you have this enthusiastic
delivery it's a lot easier to follow
along with you which is good so don't
lose any of that energy for sure not
just with snowflakes natural selection
favors the most efficient systems and
organisms often of a fractal shape for
example the spiral fractal is present in
broccoli seashells and hurricanes if you
reshoot this just make sure that your
framed more in the center and there's
enough room above you to accommodate for
the animations and this is actually
something that you could probably if you
had to you could do on your own you just
set up the tripod and flip the screen
around you so you could see you wouldn't
have the pan down but that's okay the
fractal of tree is relatively easy to
program and can be used to study river
systems blood vessels and lightning
bolts so many yeah I definitely don't
think there is enough space there yeah I
wasn't the one directing how the other
example to the other thing is like if
you end up filming this part on your own
you don't necessarily have to have it
pinned down you could just do a push
down transition that's where like I feel
like a transition would be ok because
you've got the the camera tilt up
previously if you do this again when you
look I would just look up instead of
going like this because it's like a
little bit awkward to be like that ok
natural systems previously thought
off-limits to mathematicians can now be
explained in terms of fractals
um I wouldn't move off of the scene so
quickly like give it one more beat
before you transition and can be used to
study with other systems blood vessels
and lightning bolts so many natural
systems previously thought awfully tree
is relatively easy to program and can be
used to study river systems blood
vessels and lightning bolts and I would
rish you this consensus previously gone
off limits to mathematicians can now be
explained in terms of fractals yeah and
right here I would just cut to
immediately you talking because there's
like a little bit too long of a pause
before you start and bump up the yeah
i'll do a voiceover for this one because
there's a lot of ones
for when you say look around you I would
actually cut back to a close up of you
look around you and just I just a little
bit senior yeah it's a good start really
good start um a good rule of thumb we
never mentioned this in the editing
lecture but like you want to give the
end of a scene a little room to breathe
so people can process like what's going
on and then at the beginning of a scene
you want to be like one or two frames
before you start talking so it's like
almost immediately or what yeah that's
actually that's a very good point and I
should have brought that up during the
editing lecture but I feel like the
tendency is to do the opposite with what
you've done with the scenes here where
you end too soon and then you wait too
long before you start and I've seen it's
like it's counterintuitive but it like
it makes it flow better yeah but yeah I
mean you're in really good shape for in
terms of like pacing what you need to do
before next week so I think at this
point it's a matter of getting the
animations in and the music yeah thank
you you're definitely like well on your
way on the right track like I'd be done
I like lean back to stretch like I'm
still leaning I'm still looking this
entire room is kind of
and choosing vedanta you're still
cutting and pasting the script no oh
you're your scenes together you guys
finished filming everything right yeah
nice framing thank you good job see you
should
now if you did it again what one cool
thing that you could do and I'm not
saying that you need to because and this
is fine but if you had moved him to the
center of that picture so that and you
moved close enough then this image could
basically fill the entire background and
you wouldn't have this weird gap right
oh I don't know if the image was big
enough to do that and her to the size of
his the image was big enough I didn't
want to do that because I didn't want to
look like he was an increase in school
oh that's a good boy actually yeah it is
the reason why I am I have a bit of OCD
zai consider ways on all right thank you
but I'm fine it's okay yeah it kind of
its blurry enough that it's not
distracting because i'm not trying to
read the words because i don't think
they're like readable yeah i wish i
could have given you guys lights because
that's what happens when you rely on the
fluorescent eats and weird shadows on
your face from overhead yeah and but it
looks nice
do you guys have any specific questions
right now or shall we just let you oh
I'm planning to do animation all night
oh yeah I didn't see you guys film
anything oh I guess I saw you guys from
that stuff like I pinned to pull any
mention you right yeah it's definitely
ok ok that's a good surface as long as
you keep the pictures small enough
mm-hmm and you can adjust the size like
even after you've done it in after
effects and you've like exported it or
transferred over to premiere you can
change the size of it how much faster
would there be did you think use the
mixing transponder number of students
did you use the Vixen 507 looking for
water cannon don't take a while press
away one of them right away my fears
well let's see yeah thanks dude so it's
like a lot of noticing i can 116 minutes
with the first yeah it's really nice I
think it the white bed sheets help
because they're like a natural reflector
yeah literally and there was a lot of
stuff here they're actually away hey it
was like oh cuts days to work the only
thing is um you might want to bring the
exposure down just a tiny bit because
the the whites here are really peaking
pretty high but everything from here is
so nicely like that i'm almost
just like forget it this is keep it
awaited how do you two deaths poor John
Doe in the editing software you should
there should be a way to just like bring
down the snow sherry what are you using
I think the simplest way would be to tap
the criteria and then you would even any
other get in a video game right now like
on the video is so the touchscreen you
just tap your shirt then you have deemed
oh nice job guys you just kind of
disappeared for a couple days that you
came back a really good footage Alec you
guys just work will stay out of the way
if you have any questions and I'll be
able to answer like any editing
questions you have in Premiere zoom in
on you a little bit more because you're
a little low so I would crop in like
that yeah usually do the rule of thirds
with like eyes rather than the top of
head type thing and so if you look at
your eyes they're kind of in the middle
and so you want to adjust it so like
well you guys work okay so now what the
problem is is illustrator defaults to a
brush which we don't want because that
will mess up when we redraw in After
Effects so we select the era we want to
change brush definition to basic go into
stroke there you go change the caps and
corners to round so it's like nice and
smooth like it looks like a brush
basically we're making it look like a
brush with that while doing a basic
search and then change it to like
whatever weight you want so you wanted
about that you can play around like you
want a super thick or do you want it not
so thick and then the last thing you
need to do before going into After
Effects is um go into this layer and so
see it has like the different parts of
the arrow you want to highlight
everything click this drop-down menu and
click reverse order because its tax it
from the last thing you drew to the
first thing you drew and you want it to
be first thing you do to last thing you
drew okay um then you want to save this
and I will sit in back answer okay and
then you open up after effects
football
that's a nice pan Joshua nice care award
sorry boy huh oh yeah come help I held
the tripod title voice yeah I look
pretty stuff you know but it's really
steady uh I didn't actually like that I
knew them good wee bit okay well if
after effects will open and not fearless
the color wheel of death and i can show
you
oh I can get it I have my computer right
it's like open it's about half an hour
okay after effects are a okay so we're
going to import our composition as a
composition alright double click it we
set it to a white background just so we
can see things and depending on if you
do it on the black portion you might
want to set the background to black and
have the arrow be in white like
depending on what hey you want it to
look okay so this is the fun part so
we're going to turn the arrow layer into
shapes and then what we're going to do
is we're going to add a trim paths and
basically what that means is it's going
to draw the line for you and then under
trim paths we're going to trim multiple
shapes individually because that means
um so if you do it simultaneously it'll
draw the arrow like both lines at the
same time so it'll start drawing the
long arrow and like the arrowhead at the
same time we don't want that to change
it to individually and then wherever you
want to start you turn the end down to
zero set your key frame and say we want
it draw in two seconds you turn the end
to 100 you go back to the beginning you
press space and then I'll draw the arrow
like as much time okay is that like what
you wanted to do yeah yeah did do a rule
yeah and then you can change it like
different like there's some lines like I
like writing out handwriting a lot in
animations in my videos and so like
example if you want it to pause on this
store you can set it okay so it starts
it's like a 35-percent so you can set a
keyframe there at thirty-five percent
and then you can like set another one
later on also at thirty-five percent and
then what it does is it like pauses at
the door holds it there and then it
keeps going in the remaining time okay
thank you yeah I don't know if you can
remember it all that but if you if you
forget steps of it I came like right
yeah right knee and already do it okay
thanks yeah let me know if there's
anything else thank you
ok